สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
จันทร์ค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
เมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะขอโทษค่ะผู้หญิงเขียน 2  0  2  2
ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 20  3
อะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 25
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
ตี 3
ตี 3 กี่นาที
ตี 3:33 นค่ะ
ตี 3:33 นอันนี้ก็คือเป็นเวลากลางคืนใช่
ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ครูฟ้านอนแล้วแต่แบบแล้วก็พริกแล้วก็พริก
นอนไม่หลับค่ะ
รู้สึกว่าวันนี้คุณหญิงจะยังไม่นอนเลยนะ
คะ
แต่ว่าวันนี้วันนี้วันจันทร์ไงแล้วก็แบบ
ผู้หญิงนอนไม่หลับแล้วอ่ะครูฟ้านอนไม่
หลับค่ะนอนไม่หลับนี่มันไม่ดีดีนะคะ
ต้องนอนหลับ 100%
นอนแต่แบบ
แล้วก็พริก
แล้วก็พริกนอนไม่หลับแต่ว่านอนไม่ใช่นอน
ไม่หลับเพราะว่าคิดคิดมากๆนะคะไม่ใช่
เพราะอะไรทำไมถึงนอนไม่หลับ
หัวใจเนี่ยเต้น
ตื่นเต้นก็เลยนอนไม่หลับค่ะ
ผู้หญิงตื่นเต้นอะไรคะ
ก็วันนี้วันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่นะคะ 24 ใช่
ไหมวันนี้ 24
พรุ่งนี้ 25
แล้วก็วันมะรืนนี้วันที่ 26 เนี่ย
ครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะไปเที่ยวแล้วค่ะตอนนี้
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยได้ไปอยู่ออสเตรเลียอากาศหนาว
ๆใช่ไหมคะวันที่ 26 เนี่ยผู้หญิงก็จะได้
แบบบ๊ายบายประเทศไทยร้อนๆ
PM  2.5 มากๆ
บายก็เลยตื่นเต้นไง
ไปไม่ไปออสเตรเลียค่ะไม่อยากเจอครูฟ้า
แล้วผู้หญิงจะไปไหนคะ
ผู้หญิงจะไป
ภาษาไทย
จริงๆมันควรจะเป็นวันที่ 25 แล้วไหมถ้าตี
3 แล้วอ่ะก็เลยตื่นเต้นไง
ผู้หญิงก็ตื่นเต้นหรอ
อ้าวก็จะได้ไปเที่ยวไงคะไม่เหมือนฟ้านะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไปออสเตรเลียครูฟ้าไม่ตื่น
เต้นเลย
ไม่ตื่นเต้นเลย
แต่ผู้หญิงตื่นเต้น
ใช่ค่ะ
นักเรียนว่าทำไมครูหญิงรู้ใช่ไหมคะเพราะ
ว่าตอนที่ครูฟ้าไปวันที่เท่าไหร่นะ
24 มีนาคมไหม
หล่อไม่ใช่ 28 หรอ
ไม่รู้ผู้หญิงจำไม่ได้ค่ะ
ตอนครูฟ้าไปเนี่ยครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะก็
ไปส่งครูฟ้าที่สนามบินด้วยไงเพราะว่าครู
ฟ้าจะไปออสเตรเลียเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็ต้องไปที่
สนามบินใช่มั้ย
คะนักเรียน
ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าก็อยู่ที่นี่
ที่ไหนคะ
หนอ
นอนอยู่ที่ปีกเครื่องบินเราก็คงหลับ Super
vvip นะคะ
ก็ต้องจะไปออสเตรเลียครูฟ้าก็ต้องนั่ง
เครื่องบินไปใช่ไหมครูหญิงจะไปอเมริกาครู
หญิงก็ต้องนั่งเครื่องบินไปแล้วเราจะไป
นั่งเครื่องบินก็ต้องไปที่สนามบิน
ใช่ค่ะก็ต้องไปสนามบินสิคะครูหญิงสนามบิน
ในประเทศไทยด้วยใช่ไหมคะผู้หญิงจะไปสนาม
บินที่ฮ่องกงหวินจะไปสนามบินที่
สวิตเซอร์แลนด์ไม่ได้ไม่ได้ค่ะเพราะว่า
ครูหญิงถ้าผู้หญิงจะไปสนามบินที่ฮ่องกง
คุยก็ต้องว่ายน้ำจากประเทศไทยไปฮ่องกง
ก่อนนะคะสนามบินที่สวิตเซอร์แลนด์อาจจะ
ต้องปั่นจักรยานขับรถขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์ไป
สวิตเซอร์แลนด์ก่อนผู้หญิงจะเหนื่อยทำไม
คะผู้หญิงก็ไปสนามบินสุวรรณภูมิปราบ
เวลาที่
เวลาเนี่ยไปสนามบินสุวรรณภูมิ
คือจริงๆอาจจะไม่ได้เป็นครั้งแรกไหม
วันที่ 28
มีนาคม
2023 ที่ครูฟ้าไปที่สนามบินสุวรรณภูมิ
ครั้งแรกของครูฟ้าไหม
ไม่
ใช่ครั้งแรกค่ะเพราะครูฝึกงานที่
การบินไทย
แล้วนะคะวันที่ 28 เนี่ยนะคะครั้งที่ 800
ของครูฟ้า
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเวลาที่เราไปที่สนามบิน
สุวรรณภูมิเราก็ไม่เราก็ไปทำอะไรได้หลายๆ
อย่างสิคะครูฟ้าไม่ใช่แค่ว่าเราจะไปที่
เที่ยว
ใช่ไหมเราจะเดินทางไปเที่ยวอย่างนี้มี
กระเป๋าเดินทางมีพาสปอร์ตส่วนใหญ่เวลาเรา
คิดว่าเราจะไปสนามบินก็คือเราจะไปเที่ยว
ถ้าเราไม่ได้คิดจะไปเที่ยวไปยุโรปไป
เกาหลีไปจีนเราจะไปสนามบินทำไมแพง
แท็กซี่แพง
เราก็เลยนี่แหละเราก็จะ
ไปเที่ยว
เราจะไปเที่ยวอยากไปก็เลย
สุวรรณภูมิโอเคไหม
ก็ได้ค่ะแต่ว่าห้องน้ำที่สุวรรณภูมิมัน
ไม่ได้ดีนะมันไม่ดีนะคะห้องน้ำสุวรรณภูมิ
ใช่ไหมคะเวลาเราไปเที่ยวเนี่ย
เนี่ยคนเยอะมากนะคะ
แล้วก็คนเยอะ
คนเยอะมากๆแล้วคนที่เราเห็นที่สนามบิน
เนี่ยเขาอาจจะไม่ได้ไปเที่ยวก็ได้นะเขา
อาจจะไม่ได้เดินทางขวัญจะไม่ได้ไปขึ้น
เครื่องบินก็อาจจะไปเข้าห้องน้ำเหมือนครู
ฟ้าก็ได้นะ
อาจจะชอบห้องน้ำที่สุวรรณภูมิ
เขาก็เลยไปเข้าห้องน้ำที่สุวรรณภูมิก็ได้
ไม่เขาก็อาจจะเหมือนครูหญิงไงในตอนวันที่
28 มีนาคม
2023 เนี่ยครูหญิงก็ไปที่สนามบิน
สุวรรณภูมิแต่ครูหญิงไม่ได้ไปไหนนะผู้
หญิงจะไม่ได้ไปออสเตรเลียไม่ได้ไปยุโรป
ไม่ได้ไปเที่ยวไม่ได้เดินทาง
แล้วผู้หญิงไปไหนอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็ไปส่งครูฟ้าไงคะ
ผู้หญิงไปส่งครู
จะให้รูปนี้เหมือนไปส่งไหม
ใช่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็มีกระเป๋าใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะว่ามีกระเป๋า
กระเป๋าเดินทาง
มีกระเป๋าเดินทางฝ่ายผู้หญิง
ก็แบบบ๊ายบายครูฟ้าโชคดีนะ
ร้องไห้เสียใจ
แล้วพอคุ้มฟ้าไปแล้วสิ
ครูฟ้า
ไม่ได้ร้องไห้นะ
ไม่มีใครร้องไห้เลยงงมาก
ตอนนี้มันมีเทคโนโลยีใช่ไหมมี LINE มี
Facebook มีทุกอย่างเราโทรคุยกันได้
[เพลง]
ค่ะแต่ว่าเราไปสนามบินเห็นไหมผู้หญิงก็
ไม่ได้ไปเที่ยวไม่ได้เดินทางแต่ว่าผู้
หญิงไปส่งครูฟ้าบ๊ายบายครูฟ้าไปส่งก็ได้
มีไปส่งแล้วก็ต้องมีไปรับใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่มีไปส่งก็ต้องมีไปรับค่ะ
อันนี้ครูฟ้าพาไปออสเตรเลียกลับมาแล้วผม
หยิกเนาะ
แต่วันที่ 30 มีนาคม
2024 ครูฟ้าก็จากออสเตรเลียมาประเทศไทย
เนี่ยครูหญิงก็แบบดีใจมากนี่ไงอันนี้ก็
คือครูหญิงนะคะ
ครูหญิงก็มีป้ายแล้วก็ไปรับครูฟ้าครูฟ้า
เคยไป
ส่งเพื่อนที่สนามบินไหมส่งเพื่อนส่งคุณ
พ่ออาจจะเป็นคุณพ่อคุณแม่อันนี้ครูฟ้าใช่
ไหม
ครูฟ้าเคยไปส่งใครที่สนามบินไหมคะผู้หญิง
เนี่ยก็ไปส่งครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยเคยไปส่งครูฟ้าเคยไปส่งครู
เอ๋
เหมือนกันกูฟังไม่เคยเลย
บ่อยๆเพราะว่าป้าคงใช้อยู่ที่นี่ใช่ไหม
อยู่ที่นี่นะคะ
อันนี้คุณตาคุณยายแล้วก็คนนี้อ้าสมัยเวลา
พี่สาวคุณป้าครูฟ้าอยู่ออสเตรเลียใช่ไหม
คะเวลาที่เขามาประเทศไทยมาประเทศไทยแล้ว
ก็จะกลับออสเตรเลียเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็ไปส่ง
แล้วเวลาที่คุณป้ามาประเทศไทยเนี่ยครูฟ้า
ไปรับไหมคะไปรับที่สนามบินไหม
ไม่ค่อยมารับค่ะ
เพราะคุณป้าก็จะมาแล้วก็
เดี๋ยวไปหาคุณฟ้าที่บ้านใช่ไหมคุณป้ามา
Landing  Thailand เสร็จแล้วก็ขับรถนั่ง
รถไปหาครูฟ้าที่บ้านเลย
ไปรับคนที่สนามบินไหม
พี่อาจจะไม่ใช่คุณป้า
ไม่เคยนะ
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่เคยไปรับใครที่สนามบินเลยอ่ะ
เคยแต่ไปส่งไปส่งไปส่งเนี่ยหลายครั้งนะคะ
แต่ไม่เคยอยากเพราะว่าด้วยความที่ถ้าเป็น
คนไทยเนาะถ้าจะไปสนามบินส่วนใหญ่ถ้าจะไป
สุวรรณภูมิก็คือไปไปต่างประเทศอ่ะไม่ค่อย
ได้ไปแบบเชียงใหม่ไงคนไทยส่วนใหญ่ถ้าอยู่
กรุงเทพฯ
แล้วอยากจะไปเชียงใหม่ก็คือขับรถนั่งรถ
ทัวร์ใช่ไหมเราไม่ได้ขึ้นเครื่องบินบ่อยๆ
ขนาดนั้นเนาะเราสองคนก็เลยไม่เคยไปรับใคร
ที่สนามบินนะคะแต่ว่าครูฟ้าเคยไปก็คือไป
เดินทางเดินทางเนี่ยครูฟ้าเคยเนาะ
ออสเตรเลียใช่ไหมไปรับเพื่อนไปรับคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่ที่สนามบินเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่เคยไปส่ง
เนี่ยเชยใช่ไหมไปส่งคนนี้ป้านะคะแต่มีอีก
อย่างหนึ่งใช่ไหมที่ครูฟ้าพูดตอนต้นคลิป
วีดีโอว่าเคยไปสุวรรณภูมิไม่ได้เดินทาง
ไม่ได้ไปเที่ยวที่ไหนไม่ได้ไปรับหรือว่า
ไม่ได้ไปส่งใครแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไปทำงาน
[เพลง]
มันมีคนทำงานเยอะมากเลยเนาะคือคิดว่าคน
เนี้ยเดินทางเดินทางเนาะแต่คนนี้ผู้ชายคน
นี้คนนี้คนนี้คนนี้คนนี้คนนี้คนนี้แล้วก็
คนนี้เนี่ยเขาไม่ได้เดินทางไปไหนเนาะเขา
ทำงาน
ก็
คนนี้ด้วย
น้องชายคนนั้นด้วยก็ทำงาน
อย่างทำงาน
แล้วนะคะ
ดูดิ
เขียนไม่ได้
โอเคงั้นใช้อันนี้ก็ได้อย่างคนนี้เนี่ยทำ
งานอะไรอ่ะคะ
คุณนิดนึงก็จะเป็น Cabin  Crew นะคะหรือ
ว่า air  hostess
ลูกเรือนะคะนักเรียน
นะคะ
แล้วก็คนนี้ล่ะคะ
คนนี้หรอคะ
คนนี้ก็น่าจะเป็นเขาเรียกอะไรนะ
เวลาเครื่องบินจะลงอ่ะ
ค่ะครูฟ้า
อันนี้คืออะไรอ่ะมันคืออาชีพอะไร
คือผู้หญิงไม่รู้ว่าเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะ
แต่ว่าคนนี้เวลาที่เครื่องบินกำลังจะลง
จอด
Landing ไม่ใช่ Take  off ใช่ไหม Landing
หรือว่า Take  off ก็มีนะก็จะมีคนนี้แหละ
ค่ะ
ใช่ไหมที่เขาเนี่ยจะใส่เสื้อข้างนอกเนี่ย
สีเขียวแล้วก็ถือคอยโบกทางนี้นะทางนี้นะ
แต่ไม่รู้ว่าเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะจะคิดว่าคน
ที่เราเนี่ยเราถ้าเราไปเที่ยวหรือว่าเรา
จะเดินทางเนี่ยคนที่เราจะเจอก็จะเป็นคน
นี้ใช่ไหมคะคนนี้ก็เป็น
พนักงาน
เช็คอิน
ว่าไง
[เพลง]
เป็นคนไทยเรียกแอร์กราวน์ใช่ไหมคะคือจะ
เป็นเจ้าหน้าที่ที่คอยเช็คอ่ะอ่าแอบกล่าว
ซึ่งตอนครูฟ้าไปทำงานเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าทำอะไรคะเป็น
แอร์โฮสเตสเป็นนักบินขับเครื่องบินเป็นคน
โหว่ให้เครื่องบิน
Landing  prostate ค่ะ
ได้สิคะเพราะว่าหนึ่งนะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ยสวย
ความสวยเนี่ยคนอื่นพูดค่ะไม่ใช่เรา
โอเคค่ะคุณฟ้าสวยก็เป็นแอร์โฮสเตสได้
2 นะ
คะแต่ละอย่างที่กูฟ้าพูด 3 ครูฟ้าพูดภาษา
อังกฤษเก่งไม่
สามนาที
สอนภาษาไทยแทน
รูปนี้ใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าเป็นแอร์โฮสเตสทำงาน
บนเครื่องบินเลยของ TG เนอะ
พี่ไม่ได้ไปทำงานน่ะนะมันยังมีอีกนะที่
คุณหญิงเปิดนี่ไงคุณหญิงลืมไปเลยนะคะนี่
ไงนี่อะไรคะ
ไม่ใช่ไปนอนก็ครูฟ้าบอกว่าไปห้องน้ำใช่
ไหม
ไปห้องน้ำมันเบสิคค่ะไปนอนที่สนามบิน
นอนที่สนามบิน
เครื่องอย่างเช่นครูหญิงเนี่ย
จากประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็จะไปอเมริกา
เนี่ยเวลาที่ครูหญิงนั่งเครื่องบิน
มันไม่ใช่บินจากไทยแล้วก็
อเมริกาเลยไม่ได้บินตรงครูหญิงเนี่ยไทย
แล้วก็เกาหลีหญิงจะได้ไปเกาหลีเลยค่ะครู
ฟ้าดีใจมากครั้งแรก
สุวรรณภูมิสนามบินสุวรรณภูมิไปสนามบิน
รอ
4 ชั่วโมง
ใช่ไหมเปลี่ยนเครื่องแล้วก็ inshot เนี่ย
อเมริกาไงก็ถ้ารอ 4 ชั่วโมงเนี่ยก็อาจจะ
เป็นแบบนี้ก็ได้นั่งมีคอมพิวเตอร์
iPad แล้วก็ฟังเพลงอันนี้รอเปลี่ยน
เครื่องแค่ 4 ชั่วโมงไงแต่ว่าผู้หญิงสุด
หล่อเปลี่ยนเรื่องเนี่ย
10 ชั่วโมง
ร้านเสร็จหรอใช่ไหมรอเปลี่ยนเครื่องเนี่ย
10 ชั่วโมงคุณหญิงก็อย่างนี้แหละค่ะครู
ฟ้าผู้หญิงเหมือนกัน
นอนหลับนะคะในสนามบินเลย
เขาไม่ใช่คนนะคะนักเรียนอันนี้เป็นคนใช่
ไหมทำงานแต่น้องหมาเนี่ยเขาก็ทำงานที่
สนามบินนะคะมาแล้วก็ทำงานที่สนามบินเลย
ยังไม่เห็น
อเมริกามีนะคะเวลาที่เรารอสำหรับ Security
Check  In เช็ค Security เช็คหรืออะไร
อ่ะเช็คอ่ะค่ะก็จะมีหมาเนี่ยมาเดินแล้วก็
ดมดมกระเป๋าของเราเช็คไงว่ามีระเบิดมีบอม
มีอะไรไหมสนามบินอเมริกาเห็นไหมอันนี้
แหละค่ะจริงๆแล้วเวลาที่เราไปสนามบินมัน
ก็หรือว่าเราไปที่สนามบินแล้วเห็นคนหลายๆ
คนเนี่ยเขาก็ไปทำหลายๆอย่างนะไม่ได้ไป
เที่ยวอย่างเดียวครูฟ้ายังไปเข้าห้องน้ำ
เลยค่ะนักเรียนเห็นไหม
คะคิดว่าเราสองคนไปดีกว่าตี 3 ตี 4 และ
ตื่นเต้นนั่นแหละแต่ว่าง่วงแล้วจะไปนอน
แล้วค่ะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอ
หน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]